we've already seen that by 1925 benito
mussolini was the absolute dictator of
Italy he was now ill do che or the
leader and he would him and the fascist
would then proceeded to consolidate more
and more power and they would use the
threat of force they did use the state
security apparatus to enforce their
their will - they took over the press
they banned all other parties but there
was also a popular sentiment that was
supporting them people wanted a strong
or there were elements in Italy that
that were in in favor of a strong leader
a charismatic leader like Mussolini but
then as we get into the 30s in
particular than the mid 1930s Mussolini
starts to become more aggressive in
terms of foreign policy and this
eventually leads to him becoming less
and less popular and also leads him to
getting more and more aligned with the
Germans
you might remember going into World War
one he actually wanted to fight in World
War one on the side of the ant on which
Italy eventually does do and throughout
this entire period he he does not want
to rock the boat with with Great Britain
and France but as his imperial ambitions
grow he'll find that that he has more in
common with with with Nazi Germany than
or he's finding more sympathy with Nazi
Germany than he is with the British in
French and so we go to 1935 so we're
obviously skipping a huge huge gap right
over here but as we get into 1935
Mussolini feels that it's it's time to
really exercise his imperial ambitions
Italy already had holdings in Northeast
Africa it had control it had colonies in
Eritrea Italian Somaliland and he had
aspirations to take over Ethiopia
Ethiopia at this point in time was one
of the few African nations that was not
essentially colonized or not being
controlled by a European power it was at
the time Ethiopia was called Abyssinia
and so in 1935 the Italians invade
invade Abyssinia invade Ethiopia and
it's actually not only is a very
aggressive invasion it's also a very
cruel Abyssinia
it's also a very cruel invasion they use
chemical warfare it's very ugly many
many many civilians die and this isn't
taken well by the other powers of Europe
in particular Great Britain and France
but you might remember raced on what we
learned about in Nazi Germany that there
were no mood to start wars they were
kind of in an appeasement mode and even
with Italy they they were willing to
make a secret agreement though or
LaValle let me sign the or or Laval and
this was a secret agreement that
actually would have allowed Italy to
maintain control over significant chunks
of Ethiopia but this was eventually
leaked to the public and the the British
and French public at this time did not
tolerate this and so this actually this
whole incident d the italians invading
Ethiopia the unpopularity of this
amongst the civilians in Great Britain
and in France this further distanced
those countries from Italy and the only
country that or the nation major nation
that that was not that was not opposed
to Italy's invasion of Ethiopia was
Germany and so this started to to bring
Mussolini who in the 1920s did not think
much of Hitler started to bring him
closer and closer and closer to Hitler
and and their invasion of of Ethiopia
and it would continue in into the start
and through World War through World War
Two and it was it's a famously cruel
colony or attempted colonization or or
invasion but these trends continue his
imperialistic tendencies his his his his
alignment with more and more
nationalistic nations in in Europe in
1936 you have the Spanish Civil War
breaking out and Mussolini decides to
support the Nationalists led by
Francisco Franco Francisco Franco who
eventually comes to power but Mussolini
decides to support him and this isn't a
super popular thing amongst the Italians
they're like what are we doing in these
other countries trying to fight other
people's war but he decides to support
the Nationalists
once again this brings him closer to the
Germans who and further away from Great
Britain and the French who were not
supportive of Francisco Franco then you
forward to 1937
you remember Mussolini was was
vehemently anti-communist vehemently
anti-socialist so were the Nazis so were
the Japanese and so in 1937 Italy joins
the anti Comintern pact so anti come in
turn pact with with Germany Germany and
Japan and this is essentially the
nascent accent pile Axis powers and this
literally stands for an anti
international communism so they're going
to join together and and aggressively
fight communism wherever it might show
international communism and this would
eventually be the basis of the Axis
powers as we go into as we go into World
War two and so then we get into war and
then we get into 1939 and by 1939
Germany is already aggressively
expanding its territory it has it had
already executive on the on Sluis it had
it had merged with Austria or you could
say it had you and unified with Austria
it was it had already taken over the
Sudetenland it was in process of taking
over over over a significant part of
Czechoslovakia and Mussolini wanted in
on the action as well so in 1939 he
defied he decides to invade Albania he
decides to invade Albania and this right
over here in case you don't know where
Albania is this is a map of Europe at
the time and Albania is right over here
they're able to overrun Albania very
quickly the king the King depose the
king and so Mussolini is exercising once
again his imperial ambitions getting
closer and closer to the Nazis who are
frankly the the main sympathizers with
what Mussolini is trying to do and so by
May of that year the invasion of Albania
is in April but by May
that year you have you have a form of
final formal military alliance with the
Nazis that called the pact of Steel pact
of Steel and as you might remember this
is only a few months so this is in May
this is only a few a few months before
the Nazi invasion of Poland which is
kind of the catalyst for the beginning
of World War 1 World War 2 in in Europe
Italy didn't immediately enter World War
2 in 1939 in September of 1939 when the
Nazis invade Poland but by 1940 by 1940
similar to what Italy did in World War 1
it was kind of waiting to see which side
was was seemed to be in a better
position by 1940 it felt that that a
Nazi victory was was imminent and it
decides to declare war on Britain and
France so it declares war on Britain and
France and this is the formal entry of
the Italians into world war ii as as
part of the Axis powers